how's it going bros today we're checking
out
things humans were never meant to see
number one a muscle swimming
[Music]
whoa can we all just take a moment
and appreciate not being born a muscle
that looks [ __ ] exhausting
[Music]
they don't swim do muscle swim no no
[ __ ] it all right number two
the end of a rainbow that's impossible
[Music]
oh my god he can't see over the ledge
he's not supposed to see it
oh there it is the weirdest thing
oh my god first of all i mean
there should be double loot in there
double xp at least
i don't know what it means i don't know
wait a minute i always thought a rainbow
you know
oh how does this work where is the
rainbow
what does it mean rainbow road literally
that's so cool yeah i thought it was
impossible to drive through it
because the light kept moving when you
get close to it like it was all about
perspective
the sun comes from behind you it shines
on the rain
okay this one is trippy as hell things
humans were never meant to see
world war ii decoys so i've heard about
this i know they had like empty ships
during world war ii they become an
immense arsenal but they literally had
these
i can't tell if it's a joke churchill is
still just as cagey about landings
but this time he has a trump
[Music]
fortitude to misdirect german
reconnaissance units
thousands of inflatable vehicles of all
types are deployed near dover
to make it look like a landing in the
pad calais
full decoy divisions made out of rubber
are placed in the fields
hell yeah imagine they get attacked and
i'm like
[ __ ] god damn it no
don't attack us please don't don't do it
with me i don't know why i'm joking
about this kind of horrible in a way but
his military might in the 1930s well
he's going
this is satire i can't tell don't flip
the tank
no joker on the opposing side that's how
they move
[Music]
between them wonderful okay number three
crooked forest in poland
here we go crooked forest in poland
the crooked forest polish pronunciation
crazy
lass say that again
crazily forest is a grove of oddly
shaped pine trees located near the town
of gryfino
west pomerania poland what is this grove
of about what hundred pines
what does it mean the village of nazarno
in around 1930
each pine tree bends sharply to the
north just above ground level oh that's
all in the same direction after a
sideways excursion of three to nine
feet one to three meters the curved
pines are enclosed by a surrounding
forest of straight pine trees
it is generally believed that some form
of human to law technique
was used to make the trees grow or bend
this way polish people
why you do this why but the method was
never determined and remains a mystery
to this day
[Music]
speculated that the trees may have been
deformed to create
naturally curved timber for use in
furniture or boat building
oh that's lame no aliens let's go with
aliens come on
come on others surmise that the
snowstorm could have been the trunks
but there is little evidence of that the
pyramids how do we get the pyramids
involved in this come on
no no conspiracy all right lame all
right number four
antarctica's blood falls mystery solved
a group of u.s scientists have unraveled
the mystery of why blood falls and
antarctica gets its red color
color blood falls in antarctica have you
heard about this
never supposed to see look at that what
is that
that's blood the earth bleeds because we
kill it that's what's happening or
pyramid aliens i think people
hypothesize that it was algae or
something
like that still looks cool i wish i
could see it but we're not supposed to
see it
human nut supposes things humans weren't
supposed to see
fireworks during the day baby
this is such a forbidden video i can't
believe it
stop who did this
illegal whoa it's so much color
this cannot be good for the environment
i see it now
that's terrible this would look like a
shitty thunderstorm
italy good job italy they're like hey
should we wait for the sun to go down
nah let's just blow it up now
stop oh my god italians needs to be
stopped
well look at the color what is that
whoa stop it italy
forbidden jesus christ
what is wrong with italians i'm so
confused okay
this is uh not really forbidden but i
think
this is what humans who were never meant
to see which is
plants growing in a timelapse i've shown
this before but it freaks me out and i
don't like it
oh god sweets did this why
make your sport oh god
oh it's so nasty dude
get it out get out of my sight i don't
want to see it even
disgusting based albieta thank you
a forest is breathing
stop it stop it earth i'm so done with
you
okay number whatever owl legs have you
seen owl legs
stop eh yeah they're really funny just
look at their long paws that look like
your grandfather's legs and underpants
check out those feet man alive yeah no
that's not the only thing about them
little owls love to sleep
on their stomachs we have no idea why
but they can really sleep like this like
a very tired human cub where they fell
there's a bed and this is not an
isolated incident when the babies take a
nap
on a branch they cling firmly to it with
their claws so that they don't
accidentally fall
and then they lie down on their stomachs
i don't like this
stop it alex stop by the house where i'm
done with you
you're done you're done now i talked
about this you're done
oh god this makes me uncomfortable
inside a turtle mouth
no no turtles are done too
you're done turtles your time has come
no that is not real
no oh oh
god oh i'm so glad i'm not a turtle oh
thank god for
making me mad and not turtle thank you
oh i'll be good in this life i will not
be reincarnated
turtle no sir no thank you
water stuck in grass he's killing the
air
he's one of us i like this kill it
it's like a water mattress he's got him
kill mother nature do it murder rate
seven more yes let's go
mate you gotta get [ __ ] real harpoons
oh there he goes oh yeah mother earth
is doing her private business we were
not supposed to see this
oh god what the [ __ ] moves running on
water
illegal footage
jesus moose what
no i feel like i'm unlocking my mind
watching this
okay so they're on a boat so it's not
shallow water clearly
how this possible airboats are on a
shallow water
it could be an airboat motor is not in
water oh
cool never mind tiger skin
they have the same pattern underneath
what that's called that's awesome
teletubbies without their heads no look
away look away
stop no how old were you when you
realized
big lighters were just made of smaller
lighters no
what stop
stop this this video is so upsetting
it's just a switch i'd be like too
that's not an
awesome flick at all oh my god
this is what a bathroom without any
stalls put in looks like
we were so close to greatness huh why do
they have to do that
it was perfect all along you can high
five each other taking [ __ ] that's
beautiful
love that they don't want us to know
about it they don't know what us humans
would be capable of
if we had this for the atlantic and
pacific ocean meat but never
mix i've heard about this what the [ __ ]
come on mix it someone get we're gonna
have a spoon and stir it around a bit
come on a shark's egg yeah i've seen a
ton of these they're quite common in
sweden and i don't know why because we
don't have
sharks a horse wearing pajamas okay now
i think we're done here
this has been things humans should never
have seen
do what you will with this knowledge if
you enjoy video please consider
subscribe like video and i see you
tomorrow
profit